daddy won't buy me about while bow-wow
daddy wouldn't buy me my about well I've
got a little but I'm very fond of that
and I gotta have a bow-wow got it
Wow hi I'm Davin I'm teddy
my name is David and today we're gonna
be trying some hot sauce and then try to
read some Nursery Rhymes I intend to go
over spice my father's from West Africa
so hot peppers etc you know different
sauces and things like that have been
fed to me pretty much since I was a baby
I'm known as mr. Tapatio I'd really go
to the spice in fact I am a half Korean
half Taiwanese I'm 200% Asian so I can
handle spice
there was just one hot sauce challenge
you give my guts out oh I was fine until
I heard that story are you kidding me
the one I have a three hundred fifty
thousand what are you trying to do to me
[Music]
it's called purebred idiot and you want
but we are intelligent people all of
this sounds better jalapeno pepper
habanero pepper ghost pepper scorpion
pepper Carolina Reaper
capsaicin extract ooh what you should
don't you need to have a license to
bother
[Laughter]
Wow this is literally saying I cannot
see you or BuzzFeed for my life
whoa I understand that participation in
this activity involves an inherent risk
of personal injury and even death
[Music]
cheers Cheers
oh this is gonna be bad daddy wouldn't
Barbie a bow-wow
I love my little cat I do Wow
the derry-o the farmer takes a wife why
I feel like now the wife takes the child
heigh ho the derry-o oh yeah the more I
talked the more this thing just get
attack all right little B little B
little B lets me spend the happy hours
roving with you once them flowers the
child takes a nurse the nurse takes the
cow heigh-ho the derry-o usually
determine I'm determined the cat takes a
rat a rat
the rat takes the cheese what's it blue
no no no just a little yellow basket
good job thank you night-night forget
that poor kids this is an interesting I
got a lot of peppers man like ghost
peppers I've had a lot of these but this
that's why I say any size you just gotta
like work it out he's been to some dark
places before I can tell definitely the
more you breathe out the hotter it gets
why do I feel like this I feel like it's
not going looks bad it's not doing
anything left it's supposed to subside
it was touch-and-go there for a man from
the whole size of my tongue to the top
into the back it's an interesting heat
tingle you know for me it was like it
was fine a minute built then I was like
okay get some water but every time you
exhale you were revisiting how hot it
was it's like I've hurt my tongue and it
keeps happening over and over I'm gonna
sneeze now where it's just numb I'm just
gonna sit here and just let it go a slow
and painful I mean I had an allergic
reaction for like a good three and a
half minutes and I think I blacked out I
just spit I think I did drool on myself
time for some water he is a savage I
bring him with me anywhere I don't know
if you wanna play with him you got three
minutes go via units or read more books
I just not like this is gonna tear me
apart and like there's nothing else
don't happen I feel like my DNA is gonna
get reformatted or something I hope I
could taste the same after what a
regular tastes don't taste coming tea
spurts do we just kill with all this I
think we did pretty great
yeah wait laughing regretful yeah
[Music]